on vient se régénérer ici tous ces gens
qui vont dans la vie dans la ville en
bramant qu'ils sont orphelins que
l'environnement est
peut-être un petit environnement une
famille
d'ilan afin qu'ils visent à l'autre bout
les messieurs
comme ici par exemple où on fait pas de
différence ni pour l'un ni pour pour la
pour ni pour leurs riches où tout le
monde est à mai où tout le monde est
content
[Musique]
racontent leurs petites histoires
des fois sur les pelleteuses et la
confortable que vous racontez les battre
c'est aussi des gars là
tu marche à l'électricité
atomique il y avait là robow mansoor
paradoxe on n'est jamais tout à fait
ivre quand on quitte en bistrot de
quartier et on est déjà huit cantons
ayant tellement c'est sympa